it was supposed to be a funeral
procession commemorating the 27 fighters
killed in the latest u.s. airstrike but
instead it turned into an unequivocal
message to the u.s. hundreds perhaps
thousands of people are taking part in
this procession currently they're
marching across the hanging bridge
towards the fortified Green Zone behind
me and this is of course where the US
Embassy is located and that is where
they are headed of course this is not
just a funeral procession this is a
public show of defiance aimed at passing
a message towards America that their
presence here in Iraq is no longer
welcome most of those here are members
or supporters of the popular
mobilization forces they pay their
respects as the bodies pass by and they
vow to avenge their deaths this cowardly
act was carried out by the US and Israel
they will pay a high price we will take
a strong stand and we will not forget
the blood of the martyrs as long as
there's breath inside of us we will tell
them that we are here on the streets and
we are here to stay and there will be an
aggressive response to them their bases
are not safe top PMF leaders support
this March including hadiyyah-lah Murray
the leader of the biggest block in
Parliament and their skies al-ghazali
who led an insurgency after the us-led
invasion they vowed to use both military
and political means to expel US troops
as a part of the Dom this embassy has
proved it conspires against Iraq this is
the embassy where they spy on Iraq and
where they lead the destruction of Iraq
this is where the saboteurs are
supported for months Iraqi security
forces have guarded the green zone
against anti-government protests but
this time they appeared to have orders
to stand down allowing the crowds to
pass the checkpoint leading to the u.s.
embassy
the protesters free stones and set fire
to the outer gates of the embassy the
situation appears to be escalating now
with hundreds perhaps thousands of
members of the popular mobilization
forces having the reach
the gates of the US Embassy there
throwing stones they're burning cheese
they're trying to climb the wall to
reach the US embassy compound and
they're chanting anti-american slogans
they're demanding the withdrawal of
American troops from Iraq Prime Minister
Adel Abdel Hadi has called on protesters
to retreat condemning any attack on
embassies but the fact that these crowds
have been allowed to reach the embassy
gates appears to signal the government's
implicit endorsement of the message
they're trying to send just before we
speak to Simona let's have a quick look
at where the Embassy is actually located
it is within the heavily fortified green
zone which houses Iraqi government
buildings and foreign embassies in the
city centre the embassy is the United
States as we said largest diplomatic
post in the world also the most
expensive to build
so sulmona 14 in Baghdad were a little
bit past 6:00 in the evening now there
how have things settled down as the
evening well we retreated from a near
the embassy a few hours ago because the
situation was pretty volatile but we're
hearing that as of now there are still
some protestors that are present around
the embassy but many of the crowds have
begun retreating at around 2 p.m. local
time we could see them walking back
across the bridge across the hanging
bridge of the Tigris River and basically
leaving the green zone the same way they
came we've also seen pictures of Iraqi
security forces deployed near the
embassy but of course this comes hours
after these crowds managed to reach and
attack the u.s. embassy so of course the
United States will not be happy with
this response they actually the u.s.
guards the actually are guarding the
embassy they had deployed tear gas and
stun grenades to try to disperse these
crowds because the Iraqi security forces
were basically just standing by and
letting the crowd you know advance very
close to the embassy and basically do
whatever they wanted to do now what
remains to be seen is how the Iraqi
government will react to this
we have heard statements from Prime
Minister Atal of the Marty
that he condemns these kind of attacks
on embassies but in the end what is
evident is that Iraqi security forces
that are responsible for protecting
embassies failed to do so today sulmona
the fact that there was a response from
iraqis today is probably not surprising
given the strikes that happen but did
the you know ferocity of Etna and that
and the depth of feeling did that
surprise you well it was surprising that
they managed to reach the US Embassy I
did not expect that Iraqi security
forces would simply stand down now of
course this procession we have to draw
an important line between the crowds
today and the crowds that have for three
months been demonstrating against the
government they're not the same today's
group was composed mostly of Fighters of
the PMF or their supporters and their
stance is not representative of a
broader public opinion here in Iraq in
fact many of the protesters that have
been demonstrating for three months
strongly object Iranian influence in
Iraq and they criticize groups under the
PMF for basically not not listening to
Baghdad orders but rather taking their
orders from Tehran and they also accused
these groups of perpetrating some
violence against Iraqis so it's very
important that we don't see today's
actions as reflective of a general Iraqi
public opinion it is very much
reflective of the pmf's position and it
is also reflective of the government's
position that the fact that these crowds
were allowed to to go as far as they did
shows that the Iraqi government at least
implicitly endorses their stance simona
fulton reporting from baghdad she's been
at that embassy today as the crowds
poured in there thank you and now we go
to Mike Hanna in Washington DC I might
tell us about president Trump's reaction
well there's also been reaction from
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo within
the last hour in which he's held Iran
accountable for the attack on the US
Embassy the protests outside this say
repeat in a way of
and Trump's earlier tweet during the
ongoing demonstrations in which
President Trump said that Iran was and I
quote orchestrating the attack on the US
Embassy
so both the president and the Secretary
of State is purely clearly placing this
demonstration in the context of the
ongoing conflict u.s. conflict with Iran
so this a very much a situation that is
attracting much attention here Senator
Lindsey Graham has said as well that
President Trump has acted correctly his
strong nature has means that there will
not be another Benghazi on his watch
this in reference to the attack on the
US Embassy in Benghazi in Libya back in
2012
thank you for that update Mike Hannah's
in Washington DC let's keep going with
us an Iraqi politician closely linked to
Tehran was among the people at the u.s.
embassy
hadiyyah-lah Murray is seen here the man
next to him wearing the white turban is
the political leader theis Cazale who
was recently placed under US sanctions
monofin dosage of re in the Iranian
capital Tehran explaining why Iranian
backed political figures were present at
these protests Hadi armory is a very
well known figure within the
establishment in Iran he fought on the
Iranian side during the iran-iraq war
between 1980 and 1988 he has pledged his
allegiances not only to the Islamic
Republic and the ideologies of this
country but also to the supreme leader
as well as the head of the Revolutionary
Guard sports force Qasem Soleimani he
doesn't make it a hidden fact that
that's where his allegiances lie he is
now head of the better organization
which is part of the largest ruling
coalition within the Iraqi parliament
Albin a group as is kyes cazali the man
we just heard from he is the head of the
haveli network these are groups that
came to be following the fall of Saddam
Hussein their various groups that were
fighting amongst each other and also
fighting against the US forces that were
occupying Iraq at that time they now are
part of the government this is where the
dichotomy lies within Iraq their
relationship with Iran is something that
has been ongoing for years and now that
they are officially part of the
government that is something that the
United States cannot tolerate they've
said that this is part of Iran's quote
maligned behavior it's something really
that dates back a long time it is not a
recent development their relationship
between these sides so for this event
today it's very important to note that
these leaders were there as a sign as a
gesture it wasn't an accident but they
were present at this event outside the
US Embassy it's a message to the
Americans that not only do we not want
you here but that we have the full
support and cooperation of the Iranians
behind us well tie us together now with
Mark Emmert who served as assistant
secretary for political military affairs
under president george w bush he was
also deputy director of planning and
strategy at Sen comms to Kemah thank you
for your time is it as simple as laying
this blame at the feet of the Iranians
maybe also just there are a lot of
Iraqis who are upset about the fact that
their airstrikes in their country no I
think we've got to understand the
majority of Iraqis ever since the
protest started on October 1st have said
we don't want Iranian influence inside
the country
I would actually lay the blame at the
feet of the government itself the
government of Iraq they are the ones
that have been unable to address the
protester demands inside of Tehran
Square at Tahrir Square they're the ones
that we have told time after time after
time to stop these rocket attacks by
your pmf's that you've incorporated into
the security structure the government
again failed today by failing to keep
the International zone locked down and
they failed because they're unable to
protect the American Embassy in all
embassies for that matter against damage
and destruction it is a responsibility
of the government of Iraq for all of
these things particularly the defense
and protection of embassies abroad and
so I think the this demonstrates how
weak the government of Iraq is and
candidly they've got to decide if
they're going to be a
a government that supports the people of
Iraq or they're going to be answerable
to take Iran it's a government that's
got to find its own strength at the
moment isn't it because as you say it
isn't a particularly weak period or a
moment if you've got to wonder if they
can keep control over the situation no I
think you're absolutely right but I
would not overestimate the strength of
the Shiite parties affiliated with Iran
inside the country right now yes you see
Hadi eleméry case Cazale you see Abdul
Mohandas you see fellow Fayed at the
protests but they only represent a
fraction of the Shiites inside of Iraq
most are very much against Iran but it's
unfortunate that that right now what
we're seeing is a small minority of Shia
affiliated with Iran at the front of the
at the front of these protests what sort
of reaction would you expect from the
Americans themselves I know President
Trump is saying well Iraq it's your job
to protect our embassy because it's in
your country but given the rocket
attacks they've been going on given the
u.s. contractor who was killed a few
days ago as well it's it's just a it's
an escalation almost every day well
you're right
and what I am concerned about is that
this president may simply say look I
promise to bring American troops home
not to add troops into the Middle East
it's clear that we're no longer welcome
in Iraq Isis is defeated I don't know
what we're doing they're just leaving
ourselves exposed to protesters and to
death by forces that art iterally under
the control of the government so
candidly I think that right now the
national security officials are talking
to President Trump and they're actually
saying should we be there at all other
than an embassy presence mock Kamath
joining us from Washington DC we thank
you very much for your time and just a
quick look at the live shot from Baghdad
as well it is quarter past 6:00 in the
evening on Tuesday night New Year's Eve
it is
and the fires still burning at the US
embassies still plenty of people there
as well soon wonderful tune our
correspondent saying she and their crew
fell back a few hours ago because things
were getting so dangerous they're been
clearly still some big numbers there as
well we're keeping a close eye on that
of course to bring you any more
developments as they happen